let's talk some politics President Obama
have you heard of this guy uh he
basically announced this week that he's
going to be doing even more executive
orders is pretty much because
congressional Republicans refuse to work
with him or do anything for the
government so we have a statement from
dan pfeiffer who is Obama's senior
advisor given this dynamic and what he's
talking about is how the Republicans
refused to work with President Obama
president Obama has only one option to
use every ounce of his authority to
unilaterally improve Economic Security
next week as congressional Republicans
spend their energy on yet another
partisan investigation will be picking
up the pace on executive actions to help
the economy we have many more executive
actions to come in every day the
president has charged us with looking
for additional ways to expand
opportunity so he's talking about the
Benghazi hearings that the Republicans
are gonna do uh I'm a little conflicted
by this because on one hand I think that
the Republicans have been awful they
don't want to work with the guy and he's
becoming the lame duck every day gets
closer to two leaving on the other hand
I don't like one branch of government
sort of superseding what its power is
pretty far there's some great things
that Obama's doing with someone is
executive orders he's created 11
national monuments I really think that
that's the kind of things he has to
pepper in there so he's like listen
these aren't all just me being utilized
effing my bounce I'm doing what you're
supposed to do he's created more than
almost three times as many national
monuments is george w bush so he did not
know so he's being very effective in
doing things like making it so you can
go see cactus in a place as protective
and when i will be never be taken apart
but I i get a with executive actions in
that i know what like that's okay at
least something's happening and it's
fine and it all comes down to like what
is the overall dynamic and you know if
the republicans are as dedicated to
stopping him from doing things as they
say they are well then they'll kind of
find a way to overrule his executive
orders yeah well i don't think they can
overrule the executive order EO they
interact and pass something in order to
get that to happen but in the meantime
just go for it and do it yeah do you
agree should he just do this cuz he sort
of has no choice or is that bad in the
law well the thing is you know these
monuments that he's putting up
I must say that it's interesting how
he's kind of playing into the American
people with these monuments because he's
kind of like look at this thing and
while you're all here let me talk about
carbon emission because that's like what
he's planning on doing so you know what
I mean you're getting people's attention
you're like look at this giant thing
it's shiny and it's a monument that you
love and while you're here i'm going to
talk about serious issues and hopefully
pepper that and you know so i gotta give
them credit for that um i agree with you
though i don't i don't feel like i don't
want to see this become some type of
dictatorship of course but you know i
think i think politics is kind of like
this political whack Amole that happens
you know it's like people don't do
things so he's taking executive orders
and then the next guy is going to come
in and you know be able to overturn the
things that he put in so it's just going
to happen but that being your bed
balances itself out so that nothing ever
changes and also that being said you
know Franklin Roosevelt which was
considered by many one of the most
popular presidents of all time the
amount of executive orders that he made
what Obama has done that was like his
afternoon tea time of executive or so
you know right so they do go crazy about
later brought that up because they go
crazy constantly on fox news about
executive orders and you're right he
hasn't done as many although he's day I
don't think he's done even as many as
George George about he's about equal but
you know George Bush made some pretty
hefty executive orders happen you know
that whole like stem cell research or
presidential you know being able to hide
things within the presidency you know
Iraq um you know things like that so um
so if this was a Republican right now a
Republican president who you really
didn't like and the Democrats were
stonewalling his whole thing would you
be more pissed about this the president
going and doing it no no not really
you're being intellectually honest I
make it allegedly honest I don't you
know when edit I'm one of those people
who really gets up in arms when it comes
to like running against each other I
like that more I think I fall in line
with most Americans when it comes to
that and and in terms of whack Amole
like as soon as something big happens
then I'll say like that specific thing
was terrible but I don't think the
average person is you know and
rightfully because they have so much
else to worry about paying enough a 10
for this to really kind of come to the
forefront of their daily lives so I kind
of fall into that I have way too much
housewives to watch so speaking of that
how much final thought of this how much
of this is just drama it's just sort of
this endless drama that they're
replaying over and over and nobody
believes what they're saying they're
just doubling down on party things and
money I don't know it's all drama and
there's always like one new move that
people are using you know there's always
when when you get to gridlock you have
to do something different and in this
situation the gridlock is happening and
so the president is trying to do
something different to get around it and
just as when they were going
head-to-head trying to get things passed
through Congress people try different
things like this is something he said
well I can actually do this so I'm gonna
go forward and do it I feel like the
Republicans are kind of pouting on the
playground right now and he's like well
while you're doing that I'm gonna go
handle business so you can't be mad
there you go I like the accident that
you gave him yeah business business